citizens of the reject Nation it is John
and Andrew Gordon back in the saddle once
again to check out a classic piece of Cinema
starring Denzel and Ethan Hawk it's Training
Day Andrew how are you feeling man I am excited
to see what God Denzel Washington his best actor
that's right nomination and win I'm excited I am
too I am too Andrew Used To Be A Beat cop and I
was once a Grizzle detective who got like cast
off the force for doing things my own way so
together I think we have a lot of life experience
to apply to this so why don't you go ahead before
we jump in leave a like on the video hit the
subscription and notification buttons Bells
what have you thanks to prepper the team who edits
down these videos we love them and appreciate them
greatly and if you guys want to see the entire
Training Day alongside us with your own copy you
can come over to patre ron.com theal reject sync
up and enjoy every moment that doesn't make these
reaction highlights it's a blast we also got a
bunch of other shows and movies over there that
we watch with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included Andrew do you have anything else to say
before we do this yes I do um do you think I'd be
the good cop or the bad cup between you and I you
would be both cops yes that's what I was hoping
both cop I would be the criminal always do this
okay [Music] [Applause] [Music]
it's I love the Simplicity of the titles it
almost looks like early digital
editing hey what are you doing
up [Music] moow listen everyone's telling
you how lucky you are don't screw this up
oh no that that's a theme apartment's wide
open get my own division someday you should
see those guys houses it's got it all mapped
out that's right man career cop wait uh yes
sir on your way to roll call uh yeah I'm on my
way out I thought it would be him listen as a
coffee shop at seventh and wit maybe we'll do some
business you know I just want to say thank you for
giving me this no no [__] right to that point
it's like I don't need kiss my ass good morning
sir no thank you man no get some Chow in you
before we go to the office my dollar I'll take
you Ser right fine don't I don't need the business
right off it's nice here may I read my paper I'm s
sir thank you you know what I'll get something
to eat no hell no you won't you that up hazing
is going excellently this is a newspaper right
it's 90% [__] but it's entertaining sure you
won't let me read it so you entertain me with
your [__] tell me a story right now go it's
the problem with news today man we were on
midwatch and oh uh me and Debbie who's Debbie
I'm sorry uh Debbie Maxwell my training officer
uh oh okay okay all right all right dude it's
m impression Li a license a what her license was
she a a lesbian have never heard that before just
killing it right now she calls me over to the
vehicle and shows me snub 38 and two shotguns
fully loaded and locked oh [__] she calls our
supervisor and I keep searching I find 500 G of
in the dash yeah it's amazing that you could be
out there with a fine [__] for a year and the
most entertaining story that you can come up
with to tell me is a drunk stop it's about the
the journey man man not the start point you ta
that ass tell the truth you know you tapped that
ass you put her in the back seat bam code X just
tell him what he wants to hear man I got a wife
you got a codex title of your sex t to the right
of it and to the left of it are Pockets right in
those pockets are money pay the bill who man like
how he walks on the street like you don't give a
[__] so disor gred talking to this guy yeah I
would be so out of my helment with him so where's
the office back at division in the office baby
that's right [Music] [Laughter] up sure get it
must make I guess really good money as this
particular type of cop yeah do you think he
accepts bribes I no it's not possible Andrew
he's real straight shooter she said training
day today own show me who and What You're Made Of
You don't like narcotics get the out of my car go
back to the office get a nice desk job you know
chasing bad checks or something you hear me sir
yes sir I don't think this was the training
day he was expecting no he had this down on
his itinerary there was a pamphlet I want to
make the Tex there you go you can do it stick
with me you can do it unlearn that [__] they
teach you at the Academy though don't bring none
of that [__] in here I will do anything
you want me to do oh he's like anything yes
Daddy how's your [Music] ESP learn that [__]
that shit'll get you killed these [__] out
here plotting all kinds of [__] behind your
back I should have learned Spanish in school I
took Latin you got a kid right that's right little
girl 9 months old I got four boys need a son you
let me know I hook your old lady up you know make
sure sure they're boys you got to hide that love
deep inside you you understand otherwise these
out here on the street they'll find it they'll
use it against you and they will chew you up
never wear that wedding RNG in the world I'm
serious about that all right all right see they
give you these like abrasive setups and and you
know he's saying these outlandish things but
then you're like oh there's a point you have
to compartmentalize I guess you can't be in
the honeymoon phase and be on the beat's 17
but he can kill what the best of work for me
Jesus he's he's an informed teammate you know
he gives me the heads up when big things are
happen and big transactions small fish in a
big pond but a big boom see that hand in the
hand yeah I saw I saw all right when was the
last time you did a felony stuff a couple
weeks ago good you need practice they look
like college kids I'll get education today
going to get a bushel of Street smarts today
police off put your hands up
whoa oh my God it's Frank Rance sorry sir
shut up too late for that give me that pipe
you got down there on the floor too quickly
my mom give me this I don't care who my mom
now what are you doing down here you know this
is the gang neighborhood don't you then don't
come down here I see you down here again
I'm going to let the homeboys up the hill
run a train on your girlfriend in the age of
the internet everybody knows what a train is
check that out it's a shitty dime see the small
hairs undeveloped seeds all the stems in it see
how immature it is let's roll some of this up
and test it a good narcotics agent should have
narcotics in his blood what you NOP you are what
oh not why you're Ming something your Jesus Freak
no man I'm not losing my job this is your job you
got to know you have to understand no man oh yeah
in the middle of the street just damn if I was a
dealer you'd be dead by now you turn [__] down
on the street and the chief brings your wife
a crisply folded flag what wrong with you oh
out my car go back to the valley rookie po oh
poop I was going to say freshon he's feeling
the peer pressure now you want me to smoke
it I'll smoke it he's going to cough up a
lung yeah Virgin Love yeah man he said
parked to the middle of the intersection
get the up and just [Laughter] wait
going to say Sir take as long as you
want dude would be stoned for hours virgin
lungs even on crappy crappy buds let's say
I don't know if that's the job you want to
do when you're high this was just like the
day Greg invited me to start doing reactions
with him it's exactly this is how we react hit
it John hit it John okay then he pointed
a gun learned a lot though I learned a
lot yeah you're gonna be seeing a bunch
of different stuff I love the shift in
perspective though yeah just like the things
he's noticing both because of the trip but
also because of just I don't know the complete
rug pool to St yeah I mean also too you could
also look at as like you can think from a
criminal perspective and how they think too
in they're in that state of mind I guess Mass
size hit you took dog when was the last time
you smoked weed never the um 12th grade you know
you like to get wet though what's wet but naked
e dust PCP
Primos that's what you had what what no
just now oh my God it's everything oh
dude he would be so out of his mind that's
why I was wondering why the Distortion was
like this crazy oh my goodness well
they've done a good job escalating it
yeah [__] why did you do this to me H you
an adult man told you to smoke that what the
what like I put a gun in your head oh yeah it
definitely didn't do that damn that's kind so
smart yeah this guy is ruthless and cunning and
he's so well written to did David a is this the
movie D David a wrote I think you're right but
I'm not 100% sure but I believe you are correct
I don't know if he directed this but it's hard to
believe fuka directed but it's hard to believe the
writer this is the director of su it's quite even
though I know Warner Brothers really messed with
that film brother get your ass right how treat
you give me a p oh dang I couldn't tell who was
it's stick oh oh okay Glen right hey you're
probably right just a little bit younger than
uh when Daredevil was but I think you're right
yeah dead medicine up in you yeah sober up would
you where' you grow up North Hollywood hey last
name ho ho strong safety North Hollywood High huh
that's right what how did you know that how did
you know that I follow all the good players uh
it's such a small City you know of course here's a
joke boy man walks out of his house on his way to
work sees this snail lying on his porch Shucks
it over the roof into the backyard snail lies
there dying finally after about a year the little
guy crawls back on the porch I think I know where
this is going walks out of his house on his way
to work and he says the [__] your problem yeah
yep classic somebody I know stole that from
this movie figure that choke out you figure
the streets out oh I already figured them
out it's all about smiles and cries you
got to control your smiles and cries because
that's all you have and nobody can take that
away from you there's a bar there a lowke
keeper you were just like him what same
silly ass look and everything saving the god
world yeah yeah that now have some smiles and
cries I'm less than a year away from my
dream Philippine Islands here I come and
I ain't never coming back that's right let
me go with you you're invited I hope they
ride off into the sunset I'm the zigzag
man are you I'm a cop man watch out all
right don't shoot nobody once you get
that be in you man that'll give you
bance yeah sober up man I'm curious how this is
going to affect home life this is going to change
him oh man he's going to be the same wonderful
person he was when we met him at the beginning
of the film stop the car man stop the car stop
stop the car I saw something oh no hey hey
hey oh jeez dude o love how awkward his posture is
oh my God police officer get away
from the girl get away from whoa
damn whoa not not a bad
roll damn
dude
whoa curious what she was doing need RoboCop in
here Dead or Alive you're coming with me yo why
you not in school I was just going to a ditch
party you almost became a part of the ditch
party yeah we're going to cut him loose well
you want to beat him up go get down protect
and serve brother I got a punch him back at
home to just don't play by the rules what
are you talking about this is textbook Andrew
textbook big boys have you grab your ankles
man my [__] I know people that's how it starts
who do you know yeah oh [__] huh huh oh damn
whoa you like the young girls that's your Mo
no that's what you like is you like young girl
whoa me to your [__] is that what you said to
me that's not what you said to me so I'm lying
am I lying no huh where is oh put your pants
down w list that you want whoa close your eyes
close your eyes it's got It's got like have more
pressing business oh man that was intense that
girl's 14 she all woman though man you tax for
day man that scene had very much like am I a clown
do I amuse you kind of energy like he does have
that kind of like Joe peshy wild for sure that was
for sure good good Fell's Vibe I mean those guys
deserved it but damn that was intense yeah it's
weird and that's a great seed to kind of ride
the line CU a lot of people I bet would probably
split between the two approaches you know they
had have killed you without hesitating that's why
they belong in prison for what they got beat down
they lost their Rock they lost their money yeah
but they're going to keep doing it again good
guys they die first right to protect the Sheep
you got to catch the wolf and it takes a wolf
to catch a wolf you understand I mean that's a
fair point too I mean he's making a fair point
that I agree with but I still think those other
guys belong in prison too I think they're both
making good points don't play the middle Andrew I
always play the middle John matter what I say you
did the right thing yeah I noticed you applied
that uh that choke holdo huh I thought that was
a no no procedure boy snake man you did what
you had to do that's right wolf become the wolf
yep no I said a wolf not a
rooster I thought I was a rooster you know
just it's okay Maverick you up your street
IQ you're going to do some damage out here
I guarantee you good choice words yeah but
what's going to happen to your soul in the
process nothing thing Andrew he's going to be
fine is that is that Snoop oh my
God I got Snoop in this uh crack
crack nobody says crack man what
I look like a sucker you youie
yeah yo give me a break man hey yo slow up slow
up make so much hard all right just calm down calm
down you must have to learn a little of a lot of
languages working this job he's adaptable no rocks
no rocks man but I found this man that ain't mine
man that mother planted that [__] on me man put
me in the front seat with him and I bet I whoop
his ass where the rocks at I ain't got nothing
on me I gave it up dog where the rocks at oh no
open your mouth what what is you a doctor now I'm
a dentist open your mouth oh your partner already
didn't search me I'm straight yeah okay you got
to pain to take a note with in your handy notebook
huh nothing man come got nothing wow whoa now what
is that mother crack that's right Jimmy Crack
Corn one whoa that crack and a gun now you know
with your record you can get 10 years per a bullet
do you know that now you GNA give me a name now wo
he's a master interrogator name s man that's all
the I know man [__] sand man is it Flint Marco
I was gonna say Thomas Hayden Church that was a
crazy interrogation scene and I hope they shot it
with a bunch of different wigs just for coverage
just you know for the rap party yeah I need a
res on a sand man uhhuh that stuff doesn't fly
anymore man shov a pan down what what if that guy
complain he's gonna file a formal complaint
tell him big SC dog sent you yeah you can
see that complaint a cop shoved a pen in my
mouth and crack came out this also has like
a western flare to it too in a way buddy cop
meets a western cop neon Noir Western yeah
yeah you'd feel the heat the heat is on John
he that rhymed hey you got bars Andrew here
to serve this war come on man we can't do
that hell yeah we can we the police we can
do we want to do why we just get a real war
listen we're trying to get [__] done all
right just stand over there and don't get
jeez they're going to knock on the door
and go sahor definitely he loves movies LA
PD open up ain't even up here right we got
to search one unlock the door please man whoa
wow is anybody in the house my nephew Demitri
he in the bedroom he 10 years old oh man god
artw scene is intense yeah I was noticing dude
this is hilarious what are you talking it's
a riot every uh I was noticing that artwork
too just feels like every moment something could
pop off that's what happens in comedies I want
to see that warning yeah well my partner
has it he'll be out within a sec go your
back up uh uh uh who is that voice sounds
familiar to me how you doing over there
huh you cool you cool come on oh dude it's
no don't leave him hanging no I know he's
pointing a gun at you guys but don't leave
him that was very cringe Demitri Close Your
Eyes the Punky ass cop is going to shoot me
sit down right now okay okay okay everything
is fine we made a mistake oh good oh jeez
I want to see that God War you go let's
go hopins you better give me my
money back mother you ain't no
police D Jack what over there looking pretty oh
[__] of course of course
oh jeez
wow jeez man like just avoiding the crossfire
alone seems like a hazard I'm going to be on
the 6:00 newses in an orange jumpsuit and
handcuffs because of you okay man with the
scandals and whatnot it is open season on Miss
cond oh times do not change he took him there
to give him a really tough situation to lock
down see if he could do it got both a kid and
somebody like yelling in your face what are you
talking about there was nothing tough about that
it was easy and smooth as come this is most of
my social interaction say you're serious about
doing some good in the real world and this is
the place to learn but if this kind of [__]
shakes you up maybe you ought to go back to
your division you know PR The Watch Commander
give you a nice job light and Flair you got to
decide whether you're a wolf or a sheep she she
get your rink or go give him a wonder how many
people got that tattoo after this movie that one
or the one from Starship Troopers quite a good
amount I see a wolf in every man I ever met and
I see a wolf in you Stones you hear a lot of
murder investigations lead right here one way
in one way out you don't never come up here
without me you hear me a lot a lot a lot of
red how you doing man flipping pigeons
want to let everybody know I'm here
damn who keeps the pigeons it's a lot of
great color coordination in these scenes
people working up on the roof too been
want to tell you man appreciate what
you did for my nephew you better call me
man I'm sick of this [__] man stand at
[Laughter] me dude I always love love you
know don't worry about shots like that from up
above
mommy whoa hello hey Mendes yeah new guy J hi
nice to meet you come in welcome to my house
oh no it's like this isn't Ryan Gosling no no no
no no no no no no it's like I thought I told you
to bring me a ryin gosling looking fella now
this is all El Salvadorian food thank you it
looks great and so do you I have to go that
was the subtle way of saying we're going to
go play Nintendo in the other room right yeah
he loves games man it's most of what Denzel
does throughout this movie it's just high scoring
let's go got a Mee in 15 minutes forget that let's
go a God how how long was he
in there for he's taking care
of business got get that high score like he said
St this this kiddo I feel like it is my there's
just enough Spanish in there I didn't know to yeah
it's either his dad's not there or that's his kid
my new guy who works on my squad Jake Hoy Captain
L Jacob you ever need to talk to the fed you talk
to him first good man he can take your back for
you kid died is that Tom barer and those high
dollar theft cases for the French poodle crowd
you know if you lose a Picasso he'll find it
for you a die Trine he's a good man pleas to
meet you good oh no look a disappointment I don't
talk to dead man ain't dead yet quite a long face
Doug huh why is he so afraid to speak his mind
serial burglar sing s was today judges female
Landers yeah I know Landers she's a sharp lady oh
no I want a woman version of training day that's
the Remake he's waiting to give a statement so he
shoves his hand down his pants comes out with a
Gob of extra chunky GIF oh yeah now he's looking
the judge right in the eyes licks his fingers
clean oh yeah that's comedy boy you can't prison
orders him to psychiatric she fell for it time
she found out it was sandwich Spar the order was
signed the guy's been [Laughter] transferred jeez
yeah give him credit though [__] he work
the system deserves his freedom yeah give
him credit that's the system's responsibility
guy the street and I'm going to do him whoa
the Russians don't care if you have a badge
they'll whack you you would have hop a jet
out of here you got tangled with the mob it's
cash in an account one of my old ones my first
one look the guy's a high security risk anyway
if I'm not around who's going to keep him off
the radar just tags him that's all oh what is
his name guys are these guys are all character
that's Raymond Barry I believe and then the guy
with the goatee I forgot that actor's name what's
up oh it's the bad guy in The Mask you got the
pick and shovels you're in the truck want to
dig a ditch n you are dig through the ditches
isn't burn it's all good legit signed by the
judge okay thanks to the Sandman now listen up
he gives us [__] boom we're giving him lead
let's do this right so we can all go home
and do the wife or the girlfriend thing all
right oh is that the villain from uh Legend
of Zoro this guy right here up down the flo
what wait oh is that oh hey new guys
watch it you moov oh no what yeah I'm
on you know what you're doing son what
that's for you I supposed to do this
wipe my ass oh good shot they just want
tax you a little [__] what happens to
me I promise you you never have to go back
to prison sorry orders is orders dog that
sucks right here the Los Angeles Chainsaw
Massacre Oh yeah we've struck gold El Diablo El
Dorado I mean well you know El Diablo D David a
Suicide Squad it works think about it it was
a happy accident ohoo yeah jackpot the IRS
are friendly this time of year4 million dollars
you holding right there in your hand million in
here damn first time you're not comfortable I'll
hold it for you what about you are you comfortable
oh I'm comfortable how's your comfort level I'm
very comfortable John and I are comfortable too
we'll take his we'll take his well we're here
we helped don't touch a thing evidence jeez
man I'm sure this job is everything he dreamed
of so patronizing Hey Jake shoot him well you
want me to shoot him yeah come on kid come on
hey close the lines this sucks J you think the
line has been reached yeah pow boom youngsters
these days huh you're not going to shoot them
give you took Fire coming through the door I need
some time off watch Shad all right yeah
we definitely don't want to definitely
don't want to damage the shades okay
all right you ready Kiss Me Baby One
yeah you all right literally what they did with
the one thing that was what they did Allen Rick
Die Hard Mark and Paul you kick the door Jeff's
the first one through Roger opens Fire Hits
Jeff twice right wonder if he's still feeling
comfortable our new guy Hoy he's in second drops
Roger with some fine shotgun work who shot Roger
wow new guy came in Spring Point okay Amy this
time a metal of battor for this yeah good didn't
shoot him good job Hoy you did a Los Angeles
Police Department narcotics officer was killed
today serving a highrisk warrant in Echo Park
give me the [__] oh boy the officer is survived
by his wife and infant child you get the picture
yeah I got the picture whoa dude that's what I'm
talking about Jake my are y'all watching this
that's it it'll be my pleasure to put a high shock
in that M let's everybody just take a deep breath
and just diffuse this thing you hear me Jake you
can't pull this [__] on me man I didn't sign up
for this what a mess that's an order put them down
I'm white knuckling here this dude's like called
the damn ambulance five proven decorated Officer
says that you're the shooter the investigators
are going to want to pull a tube of your blood to
check for intoxicants what are they going to find
Jake yeah you've been smoking PCP all day yep
damn I've been planning it all week son oh boy
he's got him [__] oh boy he's good if you're
cool you're a hero you're a virgin shooter above
suspicion we need to just kill your boy right now
and say Roger got him coming through the door oh
boy he's good this is a good man right he's got
the magic eye I can feel just had little freak
up don't don't don't come with the compliments
man don't come with the sweet talk he's a master
manipulator this place is going to be overrun with
blue suits go outside clear your head or shoot
me yeah he's got him Jake's got to come up with
a plan now to get him that man was your friend
and you killed him like the fly because he knows
my first name this is the game I'm playing his
ass that's my job that's your job yeah I watch
that sucker operate with impunity for over 10
years and now I got it woof the shit's chess it
ain't checkers yeah bars I believe him but he's
manipulating him all movie let's go down down
to the station you talk to my guys stand and
he'll walk you through what you got to say
to the DA guys okay just what I thought he
was having like an honest real moment I don't
know dude yeah he's been manipulating him from
a trinity of bull from the moment he had that
newspaper in his hand he's been manipulating
him oh yeah he's he's been running the whole
movie it's a master class performance but of
manipulation too as well as acting what the
hell we doing now foring of mine up in Chino
I promise that take care of the family for
bring up some food you know stuff like that
got to help out the family this might be the most
interesting day of this man's life maybe top top
five whoa is that Cliff Curtis is it oh wow it
is ah dang first movie I ever saw with him was
a year after this in one of my least favorite
Arnold sportsenegal damage I did very much
dislike that film one of the few Arnold films but
none more than everyone's favorite one Batman and
Robin kick some ice chill John all right chill
I'm going go to the Head okay I'm going be two
seconds We Roll said the heater was on so it's
my second Batman let me get the CD player oh my
God I was literally just wondering if that guy
would make an appearance steal again sniper D
oh and it's Tuco damn your gone holes underneath
your shirt I'm what is it like a 380 stainless 9
mm bar like like like this one here I seen this
one almost see yours it's nice to see him like
in a film film are you saying Bruce Al Mighty
and Fast and Furious are not film films I mean
the butt monkey is the height of Cinema yes but up
with this H know hell yeah as you aim kind of like
[Laughter] that yeah all right I got to go
yo Lonzo kick back and party e there nothing
out there for you oh no what what you jacked
Roger last the fool huh alono I think he's a
l down dirty ruthless by the way but I
like that I like that this uh reminded
me a little of uh crease I like that I like
that last week in Vegas some Russians starts
talking [__] alono he just sna eat his ass
and death Alonzo he's into the Russians for a
million they gave Alonzo till tonight to
pay up good thing he got his blood money
cuz there's a crew on standby if he don't
turn up downtown with the cash by midnight
and not a minute after he's dead had your
[__] pushed in your [__] pushed in you
ever had a monkey come out your butt had my
[__] pushed in oh yeah man I had my [__]
bro saw him in a coffee shop once this a very
interesting energy did you see a [__] get
pushed in yes that's what he was doing with
the c what the oh put the wrong kind of milk
ah oh
boy damn man close the door it's going to be
low hold up B let me get his money first yeah hold
up was that the 14-year-old's wallet oh no
hey Smiley you going to trip out is that
your little cousin or what e what the tell
tell him what you did no tell him what you
did wow that's crazy I found it I give it I
found it because that girl is being I saw the
drug addicts attacking her and I stopped him
man I swear to God don't Li me she was being
and I stopped her wow I'm going to get to the
bottom of your [__] she's my cousin she's a
civilian a right involving her no her that's crazy
I did not think that was coming back around cops
talked to you today no no yeah tell me what
happened okay don't [__] me I got jumped by
these two crackheads today you got jumped well I
think they wanted to like me or something I don't
know nothing happened okay cuz this cop came
he kicked their asses like that this car what
he look like um he was a white boy wow we're
going to talk more about this later okay all
right oh that's amazing blast him or what he saved
your cousin of course you're not was telling the
truth listen sorry you're part of the family now
thanks for getting my cousins back here put this
on your head mess up my floor you know this
[__] was just business right oh you better
eyes all right now you get Denzel man after what
he just did Ethan hog is a great casting choice
for this oh perfect like everyone's been great
obviously D is like obviously ciece of course
but Ethan is fantastic too is is that uh Eva
lendas his place he's going to probably yeah
oh Terry Cruz I thought that was the back
of his head earlier I thought that was too
yeah it's got a very recognizable I was about to
say it but I was like I don't want I'm here for
Alo well they do hate him so they're going to
let him pass yeah yeah all right we respect
the Crazy on You yeah hey is your dad home
in the bedroom oh man I think that answers
the question of it's his dad I want you to find
a good hiding spot do you have a favorite one
the class stay in here I have oh God stomach
is in knots right now yeah definitely got a
lump in my throat right now too you against
the wo you passed the test you're a knock
you're in jeez dude what can you prove huh
nothing where's your evidence huh it's right
there whoa damn jeez on a swivel that
was a scar esque move from Lion King
throwing the ash at his face pocket sand I see
you remember that fool in the wheelchair how
you think he got there talk about Snoop Dog
like that oh no damn it you see what I
see Jake job number one preserve life
Wow Los using your son like that dude
we walking out of here together no no
noi
no no
no jeez he's got an appointment with the
Russians
jeez
Who ah spikes
everywhere God Tom Cruz makes those jumps look a
lot easier than they they are you got
to get your parkour skills on point
whoa oh
[Applause] jeez oh
yeah
everybody just minding their own business yeah
it's like just another day whoa oh I
thought he was going over the roof too
yeah jump onto the hood of
the car welcome to the party
pal you called it not bad I wanted
to say that though welcome to the
party pal that would have made it
not meta or anything oh [Music]
jeez [Music]
ah it's no fun when the rabbit has a
gun is it my [__] oh my God first
D put one in his head I'll make you
a rich man problem is they all hate
you what you going to do you going to shoot
me you going to bust your cherry killing a
cop jeez man it's in his pocket like it's a
wallet give me J give me hit me come on hit
me doing his little Heath Ledger somebody dropped
this fool for me yeah oh boy is he going to hit
Denzel nope yeah H you got us Twisted Homie we
got to put your own work around here wow and
you ain't going to do a damn thing cuz you
ain't going to shoot no cop in the back are
you jeez and I'm going to get that gun
and then I'm going to get that money I
don't believe you got it in you Jake I'm
going to go get it right now boy please
Jak give me that money it's not going
to happen Jack me now you going to take
my own money from me huh I told you that's my
evidence you want to go to jail you want to go
home gotcha damn give me the money
let me go home that's right come
on you're going home to
jail go ahead and bounce homie get up out of here
we got your back n damn J come back here God man
you disloyal fool ass [__] made Punk yay what
a weasel I need my money that's literally what
you did to him at that house what a weasel you
think you can do this [__] Jay you think you
can do this to me you [__] will be playing
basketball in Pelican Bay when I get finished
with you 23-hour lock down you'll never see the
light of who the you think youing with I'm the
police I run [__] here you just live here oh
dude go walk wait cuz I'm going to burn this
[__] down King Kong ain't got [__] on me
I mean he right he don't that's the line boy
oh damn oh what a day a day day oh dude oh wow
oh he's got no money is this the Russians yeah
oh no what have you got for us police officer
where is the money oh damn oh oh no oh my God
[__] oh boy all wow oh
man
you made the RoboCop reference earlier
that was just like Kenny in the boardroom
in Robocop or like Sunny Corleone man I
guess yeah you can say that in Godfather
yeah damn King Kong did not have [__] on
this guy narcotics officer was killed today
serving a highrisk warrant near LAX officer
Alonzo Harris was survived by his wife and wow
off I wanted to see her say honey how was your
first day is that just to Echo his mock police
report at the end of that wow written by David
a solid job of writing by David a and uh did he
did he also I know he directed Suicide Squad
and again obviously I know Warner Brother not
to get into a he started directing yeah but did
he write also was in s or oh I think so yeah of
course I know everyone has can have a bad day at
work and obviously I blame Warner Brothers more
than I blame him but no let's make the training
day review about let's do it about suicide squ
but no seriously solid job by David a like I give
him he's also a co-producer too but like this is
a master class in how you in a character study of
Master manipulation of like his uh what was Denzel
Washington's character name again I'm Alonzo sorry
I mean his character was very he was captivating
I mean like when you want like there's a lot of
things he's saying where you're like [__] like
I don't want to agree with him but I'm agreeing
with him but then like but damn it he's pulling
manipulation tactics at the same time too I'm
like well yeah and I'm more on Ethan Hawk side
and like but again it's just and the performance
from Denzel Washington like brought the character
to life I mean you can always write something
something on paper and go this is pretty good
what I wrote but like you need an actor to bring
it to life at the same point and obviously denzo
I I don't need actors we got AI we don't need
actors but I mean that was Macy Gray I should
have said I knew it was her voice was Macy Gray
and Spider-Man was that the the singer or yeah
okay three I think Spider-Man one I thought oh
maybe you're right I'm not sure she's in one of
them yeah the fair whatever no gami that guy um
anyways the point I'm making is is I I I thought
I mean Denzel obviously is the standout I mean I
just the the way his character is written like you
you can't take your eyes off the screen in every
moment of dialogue the dialogue is just so damn
crisp in this film it's so well written and again
Denzel just does a great job of bringing this
manipulative evil character to life on the screen
and like what the life of of a narc uh Detective
narcotics narcotics narcotics cop cop um what
they go through on a daily basis yeah whatever
it is um what they go through on a Day-Day basis
um and then also it was an interesting take from
Ethan Hawk's character someone who's you know
akin to getting into this like hey I'm looking
forward it's my first day and then like hey you
don't know what what this life is like let me show
you you know the the what what it's all about and
uh kind of manipulating him and showing him the
rough beats if you will and you know kind of
like kind of get you know losing his soul in
the process but he didn't allow it and I I just I
really liked his character a lot too obviously I
I I thought Denzel just I mean he's the standup
but I really liked Ethan Haw I thought they had
such incredible chemistry but what do you think of
the film no yeah they they have to and yeah it's a
film where like the Denzel Washington obviously
he is the the biggest flashiest and not in a b
yeah he's just he is the force of nature at the
center of everything and then you need somebody
like Ethan Hawk who I'm curious to kind of go back
and look at what his film MOG would have been at
the time because I imagine this was probably a bit
of a turning point for his career as well partly
because yeah it became such uh an iconic piece of
Cinema but also you need somebody with that fresh
face and who it's like I think of uh you know the
before midnight Trilogy um or before Sun whatever
you want to call it you know I think of him from
Like Richard link lader things and things that
are you know just less Gruff and less harsh and
gritty than this and the way he encapsulates yeah
that fresh-faced optimism that's then tempered
over the course of the movie I think is is really
fascinating and and wonderfully played because
too I mean you know Denzel is great because at
that like he's they're good at introducing you
to him because like from the second they meet
and and the movie has like a really nice sort
of um just like naturally unfolding feeling to
the pacing and the storytelling where it just
feels like yeah just new developments just keep
on happening and it almost reminded me of like
instead of like a Tarantino movie where or you
think of like a reservoir dogs or something which
like you know you start with like the plan going
arai this is like you're slowly watching them
build tension until the plan you know until
[__] just keeps hitting the fan in increasing
ways and and I guess the point I was starting to
make was that yeah like at the beginning of the
movie you start to tap into him and you're like
okay maybe this guy you know has a bit of an
abrasive demeanor or he has you know a bit of
an off color sense of humor but you know yeah he
has a point that you need to understand the real
language and the real currency of the place that
you are trying to inhabit and enact a change in
you can't look at everybody from the outside
you know you have to know and understand the
experiences of the people that you're you know
dealing with and obviously through Alonzo's eyes
oftentimes that means for worse but you know like
it's great because the further we get the more you
realize oh no this is a guy who will do anything
he can to make it in the world it's just lucky
he wound up you know in law enforcement but you
know when he's appealing to uh hoy's humanity and
stuff like that like there are these little tiny
moments where it thinks where it feels like oh
no he's he's really getting honest with him yeah
and then he'll come back around like the second
you're like no yeah like it's it's well written
and performed and paced and directed because
so many times during the film I would have that
moment where I'm like you know this guy's a real
Great Character he's got some real questionable
morality but I get the the point of what he's
trying to say and here finally is like a nugget of
truth and the second you start to think oh maybe
he's actually being you know again open and and
vulnerable or or you know himself about something
then that new piece of flattery and manipulation
comes around and you're like ah I don't know if
anything I saw was authentic from this guy and so
yeah that's that's a great performance in and of
itself and then Ethan Hawk is a character that you
can really identify with CU he's most of us yeah
yeah definely relate to him yeah he's he's got
a good heart and a good moral compass and yeah
he's willing to step somewhat outside the lines
but not you know everybody finds Their Own Line
for how far they're willing to go into the depths
and I feel like by the end of it you know while I
don't think he'll pursue this career path anymore
necessarily it is like he's learned to apply his
moral instincts to the harsh reality that he
has seen and he's come to the conclusion that
yeah you do have to compromise and you do have to
you know uh stare into the abyss a little bit and
and you know wear the Wolves clothing but you
can draw the line as to how far into the true
crime and into you know being just the same as the
people you're looking down on that you want to go
you know yeah absolutely uh really quickly just
um before I touch on that I thought that was I
don't know if you saw it said on the stunt on the
stunt people it said David air I I had no I had no
idea he was into stunts um cool I mean I don't
know David a seems like he's had I don't know
what his like upbringing was like but it seems
like he that's amazing that you can do writing
co-producing directing and you can do like dude
does it all I mean again I wasn't not to get into
Suicide Squad stuff again but I I that movie
I feel so bad for him because that movie like
eclipses every other otherwise relatively wellik
I'm just saying in general the dude can do it all
is all I'm I actually know that guy tier Turner
stun coordinator I actually used to work for
him anyways um point I'm making is I agree with a
lot of what you said um it was interesting to see
like you know the when you were talking about uh
Alonzo just like appealing you know to uh uh Jake
Ethan Hawk's character just trying to appeal to
his humanity and then like oh this is like a you
know just I was like you know what at this point
again it was great character moment just for him
but I'm like at this point he's manipulated him
one to for me personally I'm like he's manipulated
him one too many times I'm like I've I'm not
falling me personally I'm like I'm not falling for
it anymore but he's good like I I get where he's
what he's trying to do with him and he's he's got
uh Jake by the balls at this point no pun intended
but um the the planning that he came up with too
like from the moment he had that newspaper in his
hand he knew exactly how to push Jake's buttons
and I loved like the way he was scheming and the
elabor uh the elaborate planning he came up with
just in terms of the whole day just and as the pl
as the film was unfolding just as we learned he
owed money to the Russians the millions of dollar
whatever he owed and then you know he got him to
smoke the PCP or whatever and then he'd know like
okay so once I get him uh once I get this money
I'm gonna put him in here and have him do this so
that he's going to have to go along with the plan
otherwise he's going to be it's just it was really
elaborate and I love that like even though again
I was not rooting for Alonzo in any way shape
or form like I like intelligent villains like
again I I'm not I'm not Ro again not rooting for
them but it's fun to watch them on screen like
it's something where I enjoy it's satisfying to
watch yeah he's like the Devil he's like you know
he he at least through the the lens of the of the
Jake character it's like yeah you meet a guy who's
your Superior who's kind of living the career
that you're trying to get to and who is always
kind of I don't know he's always like messing
with you but then all of a sudden you'll find
yourself in like the worst situation and then
he's stringing you along and uh and just yeah
like they're they're back and forth and to like
the incredible Supporting Cast this was a really
well cast movie too and I feel like there were
too many character actors to name um and I mean
you had stop dog and Dr Dre Curtis Curtis was in
there gami has been in so many other things and
like tons of other characters this was really an
ensemble and and like the way that they chose the
casting you have like the upper table guys who he
meets with uh in the the restaurant to like really
kind of give us the scoop on his you know mess
up with the Russians and everything and then you
have yeah just like so many incidental characters
and sure like these people were I think a lot of
these actors were either getting established or
you know sort of on that rise certainly of the
of the you know I mean younger cast but you know
like people in like the Ethan Hawk angel raage on
the cast um but yeah like just so much life and
like that moment at the end when they have that
final showdown in the neighborhood and everyone
is watching this happen and this and it's this
guy they were taunting moments ago and just like
you know you get the the whole idea of quote the
streets to sound as white as possible you know
you get the lay of the land and the sort of idea
of what you're dealing with so so much through
Alonzo's perspective that when you get to that
final moment and you see his power removed and
you see just how he just constantly just at every
single turn is just finding a new way to Wi wiggle
his way out of the situation like you see kind of
a more Stark view of you know the community kind
of servicing itself almost it's like everybody's
finally realize like yeah we don't like this this
you know rookie cop who keeps coming here either
we're you know we're we're hitted against each
other by the system and yet we can tell somehow
that this guy is probably doing this for something
outside of both like your average police reason
and your average you know crime corruption reason
like and when that guy puts the gun down it's a
great symbolic moment because it could have
been really cheesy it could have been like
an Oh Captain My Captain like oh everybody in
the neighborhood just hoists this this rookie
cop up on their shoulders but like it really did
feel like a western Showdown or something yeah
yeah we're not going to into this system of
corruption and and exploitation that you have
as much as you pretend to be our friend that
you have us under the boot heel of so much of
the time you can fight for yourself like you
know this situation has to play out but even
that has this sort of weird uh almost I don't
know mystical sort of slight peripheral magic
about it where it's like yeah it is both you know
like I'm equipping you to handle your own [__]
but also I'm I'm laying down the sort of statement
on all of our behalfs that we don't want to be a
part of this anymore and if he's going to help
remove you then then he's good by us and like
that was a really striking moment oh definitely
among so many striking moments I mean this this
again you know it's post Tarantino a bit I mean
it's got yeah like it's very own crime informed
tone and grittiness and harshness and realism but
it's super dialogue driven all the characters and
places you go are distinct but they all really
feel like these different parts of LA and uh and
I got to I mean like hats off like I understand
why this launched both uh Antoine fuka and David
a because like the com this is one of those
pieces where like everything comes together
the locations the costuming the color choices the
performances and the the writing feels like it
was authored by I know David A's like a white guy
but like I I feel like it's it it has that sense
of somebody who has lived in in aspects of this
world at least and done a good amount of their
research it seems like and uh and yeah like it
had a rhythm and it had a color to the dialogue
and to the scenery and to the storytelling but
without feeling like another Tarantino joint or
something or a Tarantino wannabe but having yeah
all these different elements of that stuff the
more subversive stuff that was coming up in the
90s and then your crime movies and your Noir stuff
and your cowboy stuff and and yeah there's like
so much kind of packed into it and it's uniquely
very sort of urban laay yeah and you know just
adding to what you just said I thought a lot of
the scenes too were extremely intense I mean you
got that one scene where the two guys were about
to you what they were about to do with the c with
Cliff Curtis's cousin and then he was like uh he
was pointing the gun at you know his bottoms and
like like just scenes like that were extremely
intense and then and building us up with moments
like that so many people probably fantasize about
if they're considering like going into you
know policing of any kind yeah and also too
just building off of that too from that intensity
I I love again what David a did just usually I'm
able to pick up like on foreshadowing stuff and
when he picked up that that that pink wallet and
uh I wasn't even thinking in the back of my head
like how's this going to turn like why is he even
picking up that ping wall what's that going to
turn into later in the film like usually I'm able
to pick up on little he's get shot and the pink
wallet's going to save him I mean usually I would
have said something funny like that in a way they
kind of did that but without it actually being
like he puts it in his breast pocket you know yeah
no for sure but again and I know we did talk about
really quickly briefly in the in in our reaction
but like I know like La is a ginormous place and
of all the places for Alonzo to bring him to it
was her cousin of but again it works within the
constraints of the story that I've had like I said
I'm sure you I've had many times where I'm like
something random and like how did this person of
all places go here things have happened in my life
randomly so I I truly do buy that honestly yeah
it has enough I think the the rest of the movie
is is kind of harsh and tempered enough that that
little piece of magic helps or at least I justify
that little piece of magic because it is like a
slight moment of that in yeah an otherwise very
grounded experience that also hearkens to that
weird magic that can sometimes happen in life
and to the fact that there is a different kind
of morality than just the one that's being posed
by uh Alonzo's character like these guys they
they they are too part of this greater sort of
Underworld business and yeah there is some sense
of you know you looked out for us though you know
and it's such a great tense scene and and such
a I thought they I'm glad they didn't jerk us
around with that like oh no she going to tell the
truth like it played out very realistically but
also with a great breathless catharsis also too
I'm glad like because he was being manipulated by
Alonzo old film one of the good things he was able
to do like being himself like it was kind of like
the Mr Miyagi thing in Cobra Kai where he was in
uh okanawa you know where uh you know so the well
no what I was saying no what I was saying is you
know put a little good out in the world some good
will come back that that type thing where you
know he was able to do a good thing there and
then that kind of saved his life in the end there
type of thing is what I meant to say there and as
much as and as much as Alonzo is like know this
isn't what we deal with you know you leave that
to the to the garbage men or whatever at the
same time it's like no the it it bolsters the
Jake character's again sense of morality like no
you know yeah you do have to get your hands dirty
you do have to show that you've been through some
stuff and you have dirt on your face but uh you
can you know reap a little bit of that good that
you sew if you make an effort to sew it and uh I
think I think yeah this this is a very rich this
movie has a little bit everything cuz yeah it's
like it's super edgy and harsh and like there
aspects of it it almost reminded me of Boogie
kns a little bit in the way that like it's not
there's not as much of a rise and fall in terms
of like this is awesome but there is like a
mounting sort of set of circumstances that
once they reach the moment where they kill Roger
I thought that was like we're getting towards the
end of the movie but really that's just a turning
point in Ethan Hawk's character where now we have
to go through the true descent you know the true
fall after the rise he he's had enough been fall
since certainly from the we watching alono
kind of reach a Zenith and then a great and
uh yeah I don't know like the the way that that
really allows for so many things to sneak back
up on you I think is is really nicely handled
I don't know there there's there's so much to
a movie like this and yeah it's got those aspects
that are kind of cool but also those aspects that
make you think that are authentic and harsh and
difficult and yeah it shows you kind of how much
time I guess kind of don't change I mean not that
we know the most about you know the true ins and
outs of crime and police work and everything but
it seems like you know corruption and the attitude
about how to interact with crime and things like
that is always like under debate and this is like
the the most age-old sort of set of characters
clashing with each other trying to figure out
just what to do about the lawlessness that still
you know exists beneath the law you know yeah um
but yeah yeah really striking really classic like
I get why this is a classic and I can tell I'm
going to be kind of reflecting on it yeah and
also why Denzel is so praised for this film as
well yeah yeah yeah a lot of great work across
the board so what did you guys think let us know
your thoughts what are your favorite moments from
the film what's your Insight on it do you were you
there when it dropped I got to imagine this was
a very formative film for a lot of people and
uh and yeah just to to give some praise too again
to Antoine fuka like I really liked the direction
the way they shot it the way they really used
perspective and they really used the shadows
and the Heat and just so much of that authent like
it this movie felt really well lived in and again
that comes from all sides but really you need
like this is one of those movies that comes from
the magic of having like a beautiful blend of a
writer director and cast you know scenario really
firing on a cylind be a collaborative so yes
leave us your thoughts gang leave a like on the
video and we will catch you next time for another
piece of Cinema much love and uh and and don't do
crime